it's Friday movie review time yeah this
one is is a classic a Japanese classic
that I just loved it for a long time
it's called lone wolf and cub and this
is actually not so much one single movie
it's actually a series of six movies and
we're kind of just going to be covering
all of them in one show because they're
kind of all similarly famed and yeah and
I've got the criterion Edition but these
you can also watch these on pay-per-view
on YouTube they have them and I thought
they're the restored editions just like
The Criterion Collection that I have I
don't think you know of course it's not
blu-ray quality but it is in HD and I
looked at them or the demos and those
people the trailers for them and they
looked pretty good if you don't want to
spring for the the money to buy The
Criterion Edition which is beautiful by
the way I was gonna say the artwork like
the way it's all packaged is like really
gorgeous yeah and it's got a lot of
extras behind the scenes stuff and
stories and interviews with the guys who
made these and these are great there are
a series of samurai movies they were
never shown in the United States but to
the first two of the samurai movies was
chopped up to make a movie that was
released here called Shogun assassin
which is absolutely hilarious it's
ridiculous well it doesn't really make
any sense and the reason it doesn't make
any sense is because they took the
second movie in the series kind of cut
it up and then they put about 12 to 15
minutes from the first movie in the
series and kind of inserted that too so
I've seen Shogun assassin a long time
ago it's body it's I think I might have
mentioned it when I did the show when I
did our 13 o'clock episode on video
nasties like UK video nasties because
that was on the list because of the gore
yeah but it really I remember it being
fun but I remember it not making a lick
of sense they make a lot more sense
obviously when you watch the whole
series yeah and you can probably also
rent Shogun assassin on YouTube also
because that is part of the criterion
edition they they include that seventh
movie as a bonus yes so you can watch
that for shits and giggles yeah the
original story was actually a manga
which is a Japanese comic strip and it
went
for a long long time and I mean I think
there's thousands of pages oh yeah I
think all of it like it started being
published in 1970 and it was hugely
popular like even from the very
beginning [ __ ] I think on the Wikipedia
page for the manga it said that it had
sold over 8 million copies just in Japan
yeah and it ended up the whole thing
ended up being like almost 9,000 pages
long yeah this whole saga about these
characters now they didn't really do
because the thing is the the movies are
kind of based on the comic but they
didn't really go all the way to the end
really yeah but there was a TV series
later that I believe actually went to
the end of the comic yeah I've heard
mixed reviews on it so plus some people
liked it some people didn't yeah I
haven't seen the TV review but we have
seen all of the movies but we really
recommend lone wolf and cub the entire
series all six movies they're they're
worth watching there they're quite cool
now one of the neat things about them is
that it's a Shintaro katsu production
and Shintaro katsu the Japanese call him
katsu shintaro katsu was a famous singer
and actor in Japan he was kind of like
their version of Frank Sinatra he he had
a really good singing voice
he was just confirmed party animal
always getting getting busted for Coke
and he accidentally killed his buddy and
a mock sword fight making a movie yeah
he was using a real sword kind of got in
trouble for that but he was a good guy
everybody liked him is he was just an
absolute riot and he's famous for an
entire series of movies I think there's
70 movies of them there's 26 most 26
movies okay for some reason I was
thinking 70 I've seen about half of them
the name of the movie is called zato
Ichi and he was this blind Yakuza
swordsman does not to eat she actually
tried to make his living or his cover
was to be a masseur but really what he
was as he was a Yakuza
yeah Yakuza is canola is a gambler in
Japanese culture but gamblers were also
gangsters and it was kind of like their
version of an outlaw so not to eat she
was a really good series about this
blind guy who traveled from casino to
casino and got in trouble and ended up
like saving the town usually from
crooked samurai or crooked Yakuza and in
his little blindman's Kane hit this
straight sword and because he was blind
he had certain advantages like dark you
know darkness was his ally and things
like that he had a little bit of a
daredevil thing going on where his like
sense of smell and a sense of hearing
was very good that's a good way to put
it he was like the Japanese daredevil
yeah they made 20-something movies with
him and they're all they're all pretty
good they eventually get kind of samey
but he's a legend in Japanese film well
he backed the production of lone wolf
and cub and he cast his brother yeah as
lone wolf timmy Saburo waka Yama yeah
the guy who plays lone wolf and he is
yes Shintaro katsu his brother brother
which I didn't know until I started
watching all the extras and he's a
badass - he's a big guy and he's kind of
heavyset and that's just what you know
Jeffy's kind of if you notice a lot of
their big characters are also kind of
heavyset but he can actually like do
flips and rolls and it's just it's just
a great movie with him he's got his son
diagonal I guess I maybe have to back up
he was the assassin or an executioner
for the Shogun that's right and a bunch
of intrigue happened between a bunch of
different clients trying to take over
the Shogunate and he ended up having a
falling out with the Shogun a new Shogun
came in they passed a death sentence on
him they killed his wife and he escaped
but he had his son with him well they
set him up - they set him up - for I
think they if I remember correctly they
framed him for the death of the Shogun
isn't it yeah I think they did and so
they like disgraced him they not only
killed his wife and I think they killed
like all his household servants and
stuff - yeah but they kind of disgraced
him also so he was kind of forced to go
on the run Iran and with his little bait
hoop and in the first movie the kid was
a baby right no he was lying about three
yeah three four I wouldn't say a baby
baby yeah he was like a toddler raise a
toddler they kind of make this pact
between father and son that they were
gonna walk the demon path in hell
yeah across to life lifespans and three
planes or four planes basically they're
gonna go kamikaze they've given up their
will to live in a way they're just gonna
fight and try to save their honour so
this kind of situation where if dialo
his son never got captured you know and
they tried to hold him hostage
lone wolf would just be would just be
like okay kill him I don't care yeah
he's already pledged his life to walking
the demon path so his dad really didn't
care about his death but the audience
cares and that's yeah where that's
really the the gimmick that this movie
has yeah like so I think the writer of
the original manga there was an
interview with him on the extras of The
Criterion Collection and that's what he
said he's like you know there's kind of
a thing where you know samurai movies
and stuff like that it's kind of a thing
where well you are not really afraid for
them because they're badasses and you
know they're gonna you know they're not
gonna die like this yeah and there's
some of that here because you know he's
probably not gonna get killed
of course he's but he's like well I
wanted to put this little kid in it
right he's like not so much that his dad
was worried about him getting killed
because he was kind of like oh well now
he'll be with his mother so it's fine
but the audience would care if the rebel
boy got killed or if the little boy was
threatened or in danger and I think they
did when they made the movies I think
they did the really good job of making
the kid that plays Diago no hmm he is
like the cutest kid ever yeah it's like
the most adorable child and he's got a
cool haircut it's like a little goth
haircut in the sides of his head was
shaved he's got a little ponytail on top
he's a sideburns cut into his head yeah
and what's cool about it is that they
didn't make him a candy and if yeah he
is a little kid that from a camera movie
you know yeah quite bad dubbing I don't
I don't think diagonal says anything he
only has I think in the whole six movies
he maybe has five or six lines of now
maybe it might not even be that many
most of the time just
looks as resolute as his dad yeah he's
very dedicated to walking the demon path
yes very he's very cool cuz he's very
stoic yeah he hardly ever looks scared
of anything he got scared of the snow on
the trees there he gets scared but not
over the not over people with swords
trying to kill him that's the fun yeah
he's just like oh here it goes again you
know what I mean he's just right he's
just very stoic and I love that about
him he's such a good character and a
couple seats down but he'll kill some
guys yeah part of the gimmick is is that
he's beat a lot of times his dad's
pushing him in a stroller yeah and the
stroller is just Laden down with weapons
it's got matchlocks or flintlocks in it
and it's got folding blades and
spring-loaded blades and hidden swords
and yeah it's totally booby trap little
kids in it it can float when it has to
float yeah it can put stamping on it
yeah they can actually ski from it it's
pretty awesome it's funny yeah in the
last movie in the series I didn't know
that it had this feature but in the last
movie the series which was that part of
it was set like out up in the snow and
stuff like that it actually has sled
things on the bear so I guess that's
kind of a that's an option you can do
whatever you hate that's why this no I
didn't fly it but yeah you can do pretty
much everything else guns in it it's got
swords in it it's got like there's all
these little buttons inside that ya can
push in like [ __ ] it's got it's got
funny moments in it but it's not really
met I mean it's it's not a wacky oh it's
definitely not whacking is it pretty
serious and it's extremely bloody I mean
do you get it their arms and legs
chopped off blood goes flying because
that's way it was in the manga yea heads
fly and our slide yeah every time
there's a sword fight of any sort of
which there are several over the course
of the series there are just its
fountains of blood just fountains and
then there's like weird weird characters
with ninja skills some of them never
explained like there was a one time
where you got attacked by this badass
ninja woman who had tattoos all over her
body and they went on and on ER or how
good she was at receiving a tattoo
because that was like you know it's some
pretty taboo [ __ ] to old-fashion it
actually still taboo in Japanese culture
to get tattoos anyway she saves herself
in the middle of a sword fight
how jumping out of her clothes and
running away backwards they never
explained what that was about
yeah they didn't explain if she was
supernatural or if she was just like
super badass or kind of witch or
something I don't know because there
really weren't I mean other than moments
like that there wasn't a lot of
exhibitions they don't they're well
there wasn't a lot of explaining there
wasn't a lot of supernatural elements
until the last movie yeah that kind of
had a little bit of a supernatural oh
yeah you know that was awesome
eventually it gets to the point where
the bad guys because a bunch of clan
warfare going on from different clans
fighting over each it over the Shogunate
and fighting each other and they
eventually realized that mortal men
don't really have a chance against this
guy so they went ahead and used the
undead yeah from which that was a really
cool idea and I wish they had started
that earlier there was a lot of Japanese
monsters that they could have used in
this program yeah in the show I think
that would have been pretty neat yeah
fighting the undead I didn't expect that
yeah and that's actually that aspect of
it that ended up making the sixth movie
my probably my favorite series because
it had a very yokai monsters vibe which
I really like that's another series we
should probably do yokai monster trilogy
but it did have that kind of vibe where
though and it was like kind of spooky it
had like these kind of creepy yeah
scenes with like these undead guys kind
of floating in the trees and like saying
all kind of creepy [ __ ] yeah you can't
get any more samurai or Yakuza badass
the badassery in this movie is just over
the top I mean they're got guys who are
just willing to give their lives to
complete the mission and like there'll
be guys burning up and they're telling
the story and passing on some kind of a
story or information to another
honorably and because you fought
honorably I'm gonna tell you why we're
asked and then they're telling these big
and he's burning alive and he's like
calm please I totally calm eyes burning
up you know it's like yeah it's like
totally badass kind of [ __ ] like that
but what I think we've what we forgot to
mention the main character a lone wolf
yeah who's whose actual name in the
movie is Ogami ito yeah that's right ito
there was calling me though and he is
pretty much a freelance assassin yeah
he's a hitman yeah so what what happens
is since he's wandering around and he
doesn't really want to get caught by his
enemies who were the Yahoo clan yeah
so he's kind of trying to keep stuff on
the down-low so what he does is he sets
up I guess everybody in the area knows
that he's an assassin for hire so when
they want to hire him they'll put out
like this little flag with these two
demons on it it's two demons right and
if he sees it then he'll make like a
little cairn with rocks right I don't
know he's seen it just let him know that
he's seen it and like where they're
gonna meet and stuff like that and he'll
pretty much I mean for 500
reowww reowww yeah they will he will
assassinate pretty much everybody as
long as you tell them what the reason is
right Ana Rio is Japanese money to me it
looks like dice it looks like Darth it
looks like a bar of soap actually cross
gonna like a domino and a bar so pet a
baby that's their money that's an
interesting mental image but like I said
there are six movies in this series and
The Criterion Collection you get all six
of them and a seventh which is Shogun
assassin which is like I said it's just
basically the first two movies like kind
of mashed together yeah the first one
they're all called lone wolf and cub :
and then it has another title first ones
called sword of vengeance second one is
called baby cart at the river Styx yeah
awesome I love that third one's called
baby cart to Hades yeah fourth one is
baby cart in peril yeah
fifth one baby cart in the land of
demons yes and the sixth one is white
heaven in Hell which is actually my
favorite one that's going the
interesting thing is that if you look on
the Wikipedia page they have all the
titles that they're known by in the West
then they have the Japanese title and
then they have like a more accurate
translation of the Japanese and these
were really funny in the translation of
the Japanese they're actually not called
lone wolf and cub they're called wolf
with child in tow yeah and the first one
which is sword of vengeance actually the
translation for that is child and
expertise for rent
I love that yeah like some of the other
ones are kind of the same like baby cart
against the winds of death which is
actually that's a cool name now the last
one which in this country is called
white heaven and hell' in Japan the
translation of it is now we go to hell
goro okay yeah which you know okay all
right
yeah the the movies actually they're
directed by two different guys I think
they trade off and both of the directors
are good you can kind of feel that there
is some variation in the way the movies
are made they're shot beautifully
everything kind of looks like old
Japanese paintings lots of snow sea ends
a lot of good nature scenes everything's
you know in wooded areas and an
old-fashioned Japanese temples and
old-fashioned Japanese houses it looks
very period it looks good the guy who
wrote the manga loves the movies yes he
said you probably couldn't do that today
in Japan because those locations are all
built up now yeah they got stuff built
because honestly he was talking about I
mean him and one of the guys that worked
at the studio that made the movies
because they made them all in a pretty
short period of time because we were
talking about this too because I was
like look at six movies and the kid
doesn't really get much older yeah
that's weird I was like [ __ ] they must
have really filmed these and because
it's a little bitty kid I mean he's only
five or six years old yeah and kids
couldn't grow up pretty fast and that's
it I mean they teach a lot and he looks
pretty much exactly the same
yeah the costumes they have never also
he's in this little samurai costume and
he looks just like his dad
seriously this is the cutest child ever
hey he's funny and it's like and just
the way he walks cuz he's little bit
he's just like a toddler really yeah and
he's got his little samurai hair yeah
and his little you know in his little
outfit instead and he's just kind of
waddling around like a child in her snow
jacket and it was just made of some kind
of little fetched wood yeah roll over
material he could and he could walk in
it he just fell over that was like one
of the funniest like I said it's not
laugh out loud zany yeah but just the
kid I mean because he's I think what's
funny about the kid and really the kid
is the best aspect and this is coming
from somebody that I don't like kids in
movies generally there are no Angus [ __ ]
but this kid is awesome yeah just
because for the whole thing he's so
serious
he doesn't talk you know he's one with
his dad I mean they'll go into battle
against like 500 dudes and he wouldn't
rat any
the magistrate was gonna torture him do
you make n up a pickpocket and he would
he was just gonna sit there and take to
torture yeah he just they just like
these people are like beating the [ __ ]
out of this little kid and he and he was
all stoic and he wouldn't yeah it was
like man look at that badass kid and
then he he like put up with it for so
long that eventually the crowd was like
telling the people who's gonna like cut
that [ __ ] out
yeah and the the pickpocket came forward
yeah yeah because everybody felt so bad
because this little kid was just taken
it's a note won't tell you and why I'm
not talking yeah so that's so I think
that's what when when there are moments
in the movie like there was in the last
one like white heaven in hell where he's
in this little coat like this little fat
coat and looks like a lil haystack yeah
and then he kind of like can't walk in
the snow and then he's like pulp with
any like fall so it's like it's adorable
because you sometimes forget that he's
just a little bitty kid because of the
way he acts like through the whole movie
so that kind of reminds you oh he's just
a little boy you also forget that a lot
of this movie's ultra violent and very
bloody it is very not it's not really a
kids movie I wouldn't really recommend
it for kids of the but I wouldn't
recommend it for a toddler well know at
least ten yeah I mean yeah that should
be alright because I mean diviners
nudity in it too there is yeah yeah not
a lot but there is some yeah the
Japanese weren't shy about topless women
or butts
yeah little kid but yeah yeah actually I
think they showed a goro with his pants
off a couple times yeah I don't think
you could win it today but maybe not but
I mean he's pretty little yeah so you
know I don't know if it's like just ends
up being like you know something out of
National Geographic and the setting that
it is that it's in there wearing because
it's a historical yeah and stuff but
yeah like I said I don't I don't really
think yeah 10 year old kid could
probably wish that the violence is very
I guess you could call it stylized
cartoonish it doesn't like some of it
looks realistic yeah the heads are
flying and the arms are flying and he
cuts up people's legs and stuff like
that flies blood squirts out like like
hoses like water hoses and it's supposed
to yeah and it's right read it's like
that Dario Argento spiria blood it's
like it look that looks like tempera
paint yeah and they're doing that
because the manga was like that what it
was and it was super violent and
actually one of the things I was gonna
say was that the comic when it came out
one of the things that a lot of people
liked about it was evidently the guy
that wrote it did a lot of research into
that period that he was writing about
and it's supposed to be very very very
historically accurate and I'm assuming
because the movies looked a lot like the
comic and took a lot from that so I'm
assuming that the movies were also
historically accurate as far as you know
the costuming went and the settings and
the kind of the whole political intrigue
of everything that's going on which I
don't really know it's kind of
complicated and I you know obviously you
kind of maybe lose a lot in the
translation because you know we're not
from that culture so I don't really yeah
but you don't really have to know no I
mean basically you just have to know
here's this guy and his little boy and
there's this other clan that's trying to
kill him
yeah and so you know it's it's basically
that and then him going and doing his
assassin of the themes are basically
themed the same themes that you would
see in but in Western in a Western it's
similar to a western setting is very
different but it's the same kind of kind
of thing yeah it's quite cool the movies
are the movies are a real trip I think
you can watch each movie on YouTube
I actually recommend The Criterion
edition because it comes with a booklet
a lot of photographs a lot of lots of
extras and it's a beautiful set now I
paid a lot for it I think I've paid
close to sixty seventy dollars for yes
but it's gorgeous
it's worth it I think I mean like I said
six movies you get an extra disc a
coaching is beautiful yeah if it has all
the extra stuff it has Shogun assassin
if you want to watch that
yeah bunch of documentaries yeah
documentaries they interview the writer
of the comic that the artist is has
sadly passed away so they couldn't
interview him but um you know it just
has a really lot it's obviously it's not
as expensive as these two Ichi this is a
[ __ ] ton of movies but this doctor which
you said is 26 movies every one so
that's like a hundred twenty boxers I'm
eventually gonna get it I have to I love
does that - is she serious - I like him
- and obviously we haven't seen all 26
of them although we perhaps seen quite a
few uh think I might've seen half of us
yeah we probably did over the years cuz
I remember we would watch them every now
and then
yeah but yeah those are good too and I
recommend those but I mean these are
both Ricky classic Japanese series in
this genre so and this one actually kind
of can go into the horde supernatural
realms not to eat she doesn't true
exactly although like I said really only
the sixth film does six lone wolf and
cub film has kind of a supernatural
overtone which i think is why I liked
that one the most
plus it seemed like plus the setting
changed a little bit cuz they had a lot
of this stuff happening in the snow and
the baby cart had the skis on the bottom
and there were all those guys like on
skis like he was chopping people who
don't like to have seen I would've liked
to the series to continue I would like
to have seen some Japanese ogres you
know the ones with one eye and the horn
yeah and maybe the umbrella monsters
yeah those things are awesome which like
I said we have we're gonna have season
we're gonna have to do the yokai
monsters yeah trilogy because we
actually have that oh yeah DVD well at
least do the first one at least you the
first one because the first one is
batshit oh yeah um the other two are
good but they're more straightforward
kind of samurai movies the first one is
like a monster movie yeah and it is
crazy absolutely crazy we played it on
we played it on the audio on the visual
system at our club yeah and the the goth
night everybody be looking watching it
up because the monsters are tapa in it
and there's the umbrella monsters the
baby goes baby goes Suzie's my favorite
with the Ahn baby ghosts there's a the
woman with the long neck yeah and then
there's a Babylonian vampire yeah yeah
that's yeah it's crazy but yeah we're
gonna have to do that one too now the
according to the Wikipedia page on lone
wolf and cub they've been talking about
doing a remake this in the US although
they've been talking about it an
American remake yet they've been talking
about since 2012 please don't do it
and it hasn't gotten off the ground yet
so keep your fingers crossed that they
don't do it yes I have white was gonna
be starring white people I hope not the
worst cast well the first cast in the
Tokugawa period yeah it would be dumb if
they said I don't know it's well it's
dumb to remake it in the first place but
it's like you know it seems like Jesse
in the Tokugawa period you gotta have
Japanese people doing it with famous
Japanese and writers and actors and it's
got to have that Japanese feel or just
not the same this series of movies is
authentic this is the real thing well
yeah and I you know I really enjoyed
these and like I said we haven't seen
the television series evidently there
was a there was a TV series that went
three seasons 1973 to 1976 that might
have finished the comic off I think that
was my understanding of it because I'm
not gonna spoil the end of the comic
right but the movie I don't think goes
all the way to the end okay
but anyway these are really good movies
if you're into samurai movies or if you
know like gory crazy
well the Japanese films never seen a
samurai movie and don't even know if
they're into it or not yeah go ahead and
recommend to watch the very first
episode of this yes you don't
necessarily have to watch them in order
although I would recommend it I would
recommend it yeah you know I mean you
can kind of get the gist
but you guys watch Shogun assassin first
yeah and see if you like that try thing
yeah anyways zany
well because they kind of just cut up
like all the wackiest [ __ ] and then put
it in and put it all together yeah so if
you watch Shogun assassin you're like
that didn't make much sense you go back
and just watch all of them in order and
it will be clucks okay anyway that'll do
it for our latest review of the lone
wolf and cub 6 movie series remember if
you like the show to like share
subscribe on all your social media if
you'd like to support the show check out
our patreon page at patreon.com slash 13
o'clock podcast or go to our blog which
is 13 o'clock podcast wordpress comm if
you'd like to give a one-time donation
there is a link there in the sidebar to
a PayPal account and you can do that if
you would like and be sure to tune in
for our regular episodes every Tuesday
and our movie reviews every Friday and
that'll do it for this episode see you
later bye